decide
if you're thinking of starting a
business if you've got a great idea you
think you can make something that will
change the world then you need to decide
if you're going to do this or not
a lot of entrepreneurs come to me and
they're
they're on the fence you know you've got
what you think is a great idea but you
don't know how to sell it how to start
how to fund it all these problems all
these questions come up all of those
things can be solved
but you have to decide that this is for
you because i can give you practical
advice wisdom strategies and you can get
it from other places as well
but none of that is going to help you
until you decide that this is for you
until you make that commitment that you
are going to be an entrepreneur and
you're going to find a way to make this
work too many want to be entrepreneurs
you sit on the fence
you sit on the fence you don't commit
you don't decide you don't make this
happen
and so people can give you strategies
and ideas and motivation but it doesn't
work because you haven't committed to
yourself that you're going to make this
happen
that's the very first thing you need to
do
and once you make that decision
doors will open up
and you'll find
solutions to the problems you think you
have a lot of problems now wait till you
get started because you're going to get
hit with a million new problems and all
of those can be solved as well once you
decide to take action and commit to
being an entrepreneur and make your
company work
here's a quick example that i'm sure you
can relate to
think about the last time you bought a
new car or you're renting a car whatever
you made a decision i'm gonna get this
car
have you ever noticed then on the street
that there's so many people driving that
car
it's not like everybody went out at the
same week and bought the same car as you
did they were always there but now
you're noticing it in your environment
because you made a decision to buy that
car
the same thing happens in your business
once you decide to be an entrepreneur
you'll notice things in your environment
that weren't there before that you never
noticed before
that can help you grow and can help you
get to the next step but you have to
make that decision this is something
that i don't have a lot of empathy for
usually when entrepreneurs write into me
i can tell a story about how i solve
that problem you know you're trying
you're talking about struggling you're
talking about getting your first
customer you're talking about raising
capital for your business all of these
things i went through i struggled i
suffered i was making 300 bucks a month
i didn't know what how i was going to
survive
but this one not deciding
i don't have a lot of empathy for
because i've never been a dreamer
if i want something i go out and i start
taking action immediately
i don't know what i'm going to be in
five years 10 years 20 years
if i want something i don't say
in 10 years i'm going to be this i go
out and do it right now i find a way a
small way to get started i don't know
how the whole thing is going to work out
but i find a way to get started to take
action because you can't be a dreamer
you have to be a doer an example i
wanted to build a house i want to build
my dream house
and i didn't know how i was gonna afford
it i didn't know what it was gonna cost
i didn't know any architects i didn't
know anything about layout furniture
none of that stuff i didn't know any of
that stuff but once i made that decision
i want to build a house
it wasn't months of i think i should
build the house i wish i built the house
in 10 years here's the house i want to
have i went out and i started doing it
i made an appointment with a real estate
agent started doing tours found a lot in
an area that i liked i bought it
then i found the construction company
and i found an architect and i found
designers and i found everything i
needed to build this house
i made it happen
so i'm not a dreamer and if you want to
have success as an entrepreneur you
can't just be a dreamer you've got to be
a doer you've got to take action on what
you want to happen
now that's not saying you don't have to
have a big vision
i want to help a billion entrepreneurs
that's my vision that's my goal and
every day i'm taking action to move
closer to that goal
that's a big picture thing i want to
accomplish
you guys watching this video right now
you're helping me get to my goal
so whatever you have as a goal your
vision whatever it is you have to take
steps you got to commit to it you got to
say this is going to happen i'm going to
find a way until you do that you're not
going to have success and all the people
who try to help you
their words are gonna fall on deaf ears
you may say that's a great idea yeah i
should really do that wow that's that's
some great advice you gotta take it you
gotta take action you have to do
something
you've gotta commit to
yourself this is all in response to an
email that came in from one of my
facebook fans stephen and steven has
this idea for a business
selling christmas cakes from his nana's
great recipe
and he wrote this whole long thing but
the summary is he's got this great
recipe this is nana's recipe everybody
says you've got this great thing you
should go out and you should make this a
business and he's on the fence he
doesn't know how to fund it he doesn't
know how to get it started he doesn't
know if it should be a seasonal thing or
full-time business he doesn't know if he
can do it while still doing his job he
doesn't know what to do
there's tons of steps that you can do
there's tons of ways to promote this
business you can partner up with
different companies you can make it a
seasonal business to start and see if
you like it you can partner up with
online websites who have a market that
you can tap into you could partner up
with media or bloggers or people who can
spread your message you're talking to me
about your favorite christmas cake and
how great this is how everybody loves it
send me a cake
right let me try it let me tell the
world about it if i love a product i
talk about it i tell my friends i make a
video about it
so don't just send the message send the
cake right this is how you can get out
there
but none of this matters none of these
steps matter until you commit to making
this happen
you have to decide
i'm going to be an entrepreneur i'm
going to find a way to make my dream
happen and when you do that you start
finding solutions and you start
acting on them
so if you're on the fence right now
i get that it's tough i get that it's
scary i get that
you may not have done this before you're
worried about putting your family at
risk you want to put in your job at risk
but if you love this idea
i don't want you to sit around for the
next 20 years and wish that you had done
something about it look back on your
life and say
wow that was such a great idea and you
watch other people make tons of money
off of it where you could have had that
impact that could have been you
it's hard it's scary
but if you want
this dream to happen
you've got to stop dreaming
you've got to start being a doer start
taking action and it begins with a
simple decision
decide that you're going to be an
entrepreneur decide that this dream is
going to happen for you and you're going
to start today and do something today
and do something tomorrow and do
something the next day every day taking
small actions
to move your business forward and i'm
not saying get off the fence and jump
into the deep end i'm not saying get out
the fence and quit your job and go crazy
full-time for three months and then burn
through your cash and run out and have
to go back and get a job okay that's not
my message
get off the fence and start small that's
cool keep your job
start part-time but you started you made
a decision things are happening
until you decide
until you go from being a wannabe
entrepreneur to doing something and
being a real entrepreneur even part-time
but you're an entrepreneur now
until you make that decision nothing's
going to happen to you nothing will
happen and all the advice wisdom ideas
in the world will not help you until you
decide to become an entrepreneur
so make that decision and make it
powerfully
believe
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes me want to do more for you and
let me know what you think
let me know how you decided to be an
entrepreneur if you have a question for
your business leave it in the comments
below i'd make a video response for you
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
you